hey guys this is dennis i found anything
here and i'm david griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the walking dead season
4 episode 6 live bait so this is a
governor centric episode all the
governor um so nothing in the prison
nothing with ray or Darrell anything
like that look I would have been fine
with this episode if this was like some
sort of almost like a side thing like a
I don't know web series we were watching
yeah great webisode like a sign thing
when I don't know about this as like the
entire episode yeah I mean if this is
just to get the whole episodes in
meaning was to get to the point where
the governor gets his daughter back I
don't know if that's worth an hour of
television David Morris he's a great
actor but I don't know though the end
game is worth it i don't know we'll see
well it looks like to that it's not
self-contained into just this episode it
looks like next week episode is also all
governor as well so it's it's more than
just even a standalone episode it's it's
a two maybe three episode are yeah yeah
away from everybody the prison yeah so
it's like what we're talking about in
previous reviews that it just seems like
they're stretching out there taking
gotta give that a 16 episode that's a
story and then just stretching out i
mean i feel like there is some good
stuff in there about the governor and
his character development but they're
just taking such a long right way to do
it just like the last episode like there
were some good stuff in it but they just
take whatever you know amount of story
that it is right and just stretch it out
and i think that's what they're doing
with the governor yeah I mean it's again
it's good David Moyes I said I like him
as an actor he's good he's solid but
yeah it's like the whole episode is just
we're going to this whole process of him
mean these people and you know I mean I
guess maybe he's turning to a kind of a
better guy and under the ND meets up i
think it's Martinez again and so we'll
see how meeting up with his old group of
people how that's gonna work but it's
like I don't know I just I'm not sure I
want I'm glad that he's back in the show
I kind of think it could I'm really in a
positive note I mean he could bring some
some new life into this show I think
once he gets me to the prayer
whenever he does get up there I guess
this is the backstory of that it could
be good but maybe I would have liked to
see maybe bounce back and forth maybe go
to prison and then do this story you can
do the story I don't hear the whole
episode I wish they had just weaved in
this whole governor storyline right
throughout this whole prison flu cuz i
woulda made it because I know you guys
heard us I've know I've complained about
the show not moving enough just stuck in
the same Posada same spot all the time
this has been a great way to do that
we've got kind of a new setting every
week to kind of learn about the governor
but also learn about the people in the
prison I think that would have been a
better way to stuff yeah instead of
doing two or three of these standalone
governor episodes they should have
weaved this story line into all the flu
storyline you know on the side so then
we have kind of two things that are
going on actually maybe three things so
you had a Darrell on his group going on
and in that way would have I think kept
things flowing a lot better but i think
this decision to like separate it i
don't know if it's such a good one
especially for the pacing purposes of
the show yeah I mean I again and again
more new characters yeah you know we'll
see if they survive every time we see
new characters like just gonna get
killed off it's like when the introduces
new characters melody is her name the
woman you know I guess the she's older
sister older sister the leader who's
also an arrow and been in some other
shows in the past and she's against new
character but I don't open even start
caring about her already or she's gonna
get killed off again I mean that I'm
assuming that i'm assuming that her and
the sister and probably even the
daughter dies before he writes to the
prison I'm just I'm just speculating to
the prison that kind of show him at
least always see if it was just him
alone looking at the prison so you
wonder if anybody even makes it out I
mean the one thing I did like ever the
episode was showing a little more depth
to the governor knowing that he's not
like an evil right person I mean he's
messed in the head and yeah I'm he's a
bad person but it was not pure evil it's
not like I like all he wants to do is
kill people know that it's more like oh
he's just a twisted demented guy and
sometimes he goes crazy and I'm guessing
that's how this storyline is gonna end
with him he's gonna do something great
back there's always I mean you know
being kind of criticizing the show last
few weeks no
lot of you out there saying you know
stop watching the show just give it up
you know either you mean realize that
you know just because you notice I both
liked the show we've both invested in
the comic book series just because we
don't like the last few episodes doesn't
mean we hate everything about the show
you can like a show and not like
everything about it I don't know there's
no thing react to like like every single
episode is perfect even writers don't
think the talk to writers I don't even
think every episodes perfect so this
episode I could see some positives in
here I think there's walking that is a
great job with set pieces yeah the set
piece with the the governor and the DA
the little girl in the pit that was kind
of cool you know him seeing you know
being the gov cuz governor is a badass
you know he is that was kind of see him
cool take down some zombies but I don't
know I don't know why the girl fell and
broke her ankle do I don't really get
there you're a croach like oh and then
just like fell over I'm like wait how
did you yeah I just for me personally
that the pacing of is it is slow and
they need to break it up and just you
know they're just stretching everything
out no stretching it thin right and I
you know I it's not that it's not like
we don't like the show it's just this
show has really put on the brakes yeah I
mean slowed really down we spent all
that time this last few weeks with the
whole illness sickness everybody dying
and Glenn you know coffin for 45 but all
of a sudden it's like oh now or the
governor for a spinoff oh yeah that's
been uh I'm sorry but a backstory now
next week was I couldn't get another
backstory so this was a little
disjointed which is bothering me a
little bit but I'm glad David morsi's
back I'm glad to see yeah it's a very
good at oh yeah I think potentially this
can lead into a much more interesting
storyline mmm for future episodes right
right now it's it's a little stagnant
for me yeah we'll see what happens you
know Walking Dead will continue uh and
then you know also I mean we had the
whole governor burning the picture of
his family kind of supposedly signifying
like okay he's gonna I don't know like
not so much let go of his family but
just like let go of himself as that
person you know at first he folded that
picture up yeah so you couldn't see
himself and can only
his daughter and his wife and now he
burnt it so it's almost like he's just
like okay I'm gonna I'm just gonna be
some crazy mofo now yeah I mean is he's
doing this thing I mean was I'm
curiously with you know who see Martinez
and his boys in the one that the big
dude who just looked serious doesn't say
anything but uh you know he got i'm
assuming got separated from no I thought
maybe they might have died but obviously
they're still around so it's gonna be
curious to see next week what their
dynamic is and how that because governor
doesn't really have any power anymore
technically so it gives you to see what
happens when those two camps merge yeah
alright guys so let us know what you
thought of the episode if you'd like
they're not or if you think a this
governor storyline is worthwhile you can
post your comments on the website thank
yo calm or on our YouTube channel let's
think your all-pro make sure you
subscribe to that we're gonna check us
out on twitter com top of this child is
about walking dead what you love what
you hate which you wish we would like
about the show you can find Dennis and I
both I think hero i'm at griffin de and
we also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think carroll fans
make sure you like that page and you
tweet out our video and share it on
facebook and stuff like that thanks
you